so if you missed my first video
introducing the Armageddon championship
series this is your second chance uh
this is played on chessarena.com which
is the official playing platform of fide
and they're putting up a whopping 460
000 Euro prize fund for the series of
tournaments and the way this works is
there are various online Regional cups
and if you do well in those then you can
qualify for the online finals and then
ultimately there is over the board
events with uh just a huge amount of
prizes
so in this video you'll see me play in
my second online Regional cup which I
originally streamed on November 12th and
I will say that there was a surprise
twist at the end and I don't want to
reveal too much but
um I may or may not have encountered
someone who is disqualified for a fair
play violation so I think I'll leave it
at that but uh this platform does take
fair play very seriously they have a
very robust system for uh handling fair
play violations and uh apart from that
it was a a fun tournament and I do hope
you learn a thing or two and if you're
interested in playing in this event I do
have more information in the links below
to participate you do need a pro account
and I do have a coupon code Rosen to
save on your pro accounts so feel free
to check out links in the video
description for all the information
I do hope you enjoy the video and here
we go
um
E4
I'm using alerts no ponziani
can't fulfill the promise
but we have some kind of Sicilian
Knight F6
so opponent wants a special carve
I was watching donya's stream earlier he
had like a very similar opening against
Chicago
[Music]
like very similar
uh I don't know the theory here I want
to say E5
I studied this at some point
oh I do remember the theory there is um
a Carlson carwana game
with the sign like the thread is nine F7
I think
it's been so long since I looked at this
I'm not mistaken like F6 is a move
not sure though
I give E6 I play Knight E4 and then
Target the D6 Square
this is actually a really cool opening
to start the the tournament
I like the fat my points thinking here
and queen F3 is also
probably a big threat
yeah now Knight D6 was guaranteed
there's Queen G5 no there's not Queen G5
I was thinking Queen G5 working both
undefended Pawns
I would lose a queen though
maybe later like yeah Queen will try and
do some damage
I'm actually thinking D3 here
like no reason to rush
because I want to play Bishop G5
oh
so what's happening
Queen G4
I'm also realizing I have the C4
resource
it's weird though
it looks really close to winning
oh there's a cool line let's start with
F3
and after it takes I play Knight D6
takes takes King f8 and then Castle
yeah this way I
I keep the f file open
looks like there should be some mating
attack
hmm
which is Bishop D2
and this is full domination
layout layout still looks fine
cool okay
let's play this
uh Bishop A6
considering C4
I'll start with Rick iPhone
7
but no mercy here
okay where's the wind
it looks close
uh maybe just D4
and box completely stuck
okay now the bishop has some life though
when the pawn
maybe I'll just push my Apon
will be my winning plan
okay I learned my lesson from earlier
don't get too comfortable even in a
winning position
[Music]
uh let's play this move
black is still fighting
I broke off one was a meat threat there
Bishop G5
trying to clamp down
another thing I could play Bishop
I could consider Bishop E7
that does allow Knight takes
but there's I mean there's so many ways
to win this
okay let's take
check
okay
there we go that was the first game
it's a nice game overall
okay here we go
new opponent
playing
the name continues but uh maybe go Mouse
okay alerts are still muted this is game
two
you can click on my opponent
of Gonzalo from Chile
okay so we have one of these
I'm gonna play Knight C4
foreign
I like this transformation because
White's left with this isolated d-pawn
and there's ideas of Bishop F6
my queen side pawns are smiling
I'm thinking A5
although I have to be careful of like
weird tactics
maybe rookie six
for pair Queen E7
I think I'll go for the Triple up on the
e-file
a rook EA coming next
F3
does defend the Rook I could take the
bishop
and pawn takes
hmm
let's start with this
a lot of pressure against E5 like E5 is
a main focal points I have four
attackers but white has five Defenders
now the Knight wants to go to F6
thinking about A5 here
that's one way to
oh I missed this
actually is it so bad
oh
takes
I just wondered that
I mean I could take
some messy trade
and the bishop covers G7
wow
first thing that comes to mind is Queen
E1
to take
yeah Queenie one is simple
if I have a rook no two Rooks on a
knight for Queen and pong
and this is made in two
okay
that was a cool game
I made one kind of big oversight that
game
losing H6 but it didn't cost me too much
yeah I tilted White's King
like King gets really tilted when it
gets checkmated I guess
okay next opponent
okay so I'm playing Jose Gabriel zuluaga
I'll play London probably upon's offline
Alpine's online
okay
new game
it's my London prep
I think H4
I'm so tempted to play G4
I could play H5 first
there's a few ideas one is G4 G5 another
idea is like Queen F3 Queen G3
Queen G4 threatening Bishop H6
um so if I take
yeah in the end of this after Queen G3
I'll be threatening
C7 and H6
assuming Knight takes
it depends which Knight takes I mean The
Rook could take or the queen could take
as well
maybe it's not so simple
[Music]
yeah the Knight defense C7 here so I'm
still threatening Bishop H6
and I want to get my knight in probably
to E5 and then maybe eventually to G6
but if I play Knight F3 too soon there's
Queen B4
hmm
maybe C3
it seems like a slow move but uh
prevents counter play
and now I want to go in with the Knights
I think just Knights E5 oh no my Bishop
because Knight G6 is a triple Fork
threat
that's still tricky like King G8 Knight
G6
Queen moves I take the Rook
I'll be winning the exchange
I almost forgot I had tea
drinking some
Japanese sencha green tea
I think opponent was realizing there
troubles there
and Bishop G6
a nice position
up the exchange got the bishop pair
I'm making way for the g-pawn
yeah the king is actually just very safe
in the center
no need to Castle
[Music]
foreign
thinking G5 anyway
the Queen's tied down to defending the
Knight on E8
so Pawn takes G5 I can take the Knight
and then take the pawn
H6 coming soon
I have g6h7 oh oh there's a funny line
or is there
maybe I'll just Castle first
or King D2 let's play King D2
and the King's safer on D2
the center files are not open yet
the point is to bring the
the final Rook into the game
so if Rook F5 I play H7 King h8 and then
Kelly sack maybe I can't sack
um
let's play this Pawn Jake's Pawn
I take back
do I have to be careful
and queen E4 I play H7
okay this should be an easy win now
and rookie chase the threat
okay
it's Joe Bava thanks for the rage obava
shout out to James blunder
if you're just adjoining
um this is
the Armageddon championship series
I'm playing in the tournament with a
prize fund of 1 000 Euros and that was
round that was around three I think
there we go
oh playing a strong player
playing International master
Fernandez De La Vara
you just have to stay focused
opponent's higher rated than me
King's Indian attack
and B3
it was very positional line
preventing that E5
I think I just want to play like Queen
E7 rookie 8.
just get a solid setup
there's some idea in the H4 which
usually calls for G6
preventing other five
there's something like G4 idea two
or Knight E4
Queen E3
I play Knight E4 there's Knights
95
I'm thinking about C5 as well
hmm
I'll go for this
so 95 I'll take on C3 and then F6
I mean basically it meets the trades
but I just want like a simple position
where I can
pressure the e-file
of course remove the Knight Knight G6
doesn't scare me I'm taking Queen G7
and I have three I'd probably take on G2
or on on E2
so I probably have to take
and then I can focus on the e-file
pressure
foreign
[Music]
it's a crazy move
I can't quite get away with taking
I take on E2
take on E2 doesn't look that great I
think Bishop B4
very clever move
Bishop before is the way to go
I mean C7 is that one defended
maybe King G7
staying up on time so that's good
randomly offering a draw
this is okay and there's 9 95 takes Rook
C7 Bishop C8
a Rookie's having Queen one
before might be coming
um
not the most Pleasant position huh
we have Knight C5
I want to play 94.
so D5 not played
hmm
that's a good move
I'm just worse here
and I see six Rook ac-8s
Queen's actually well placed on D5
that's my idea like E3 C5
foreign
foreign
[Music]
unpleasant position
rugby when I play C5 D5 B5
I still go for the same plan
this isn't so bad actually
so I'm gonna probably win the C Pawn
there's Rooks
rookie six
start pushing
hmm
hey Rook C7
oh
up on time which is good
let me trade Rooks I win
a good move
okay
got a dirty flag there
it's still a tricky position
um I mean I'm not quite mating but
uh that was a hard fought game
GG
oh next game starting that was a final
game of the round
oh there's not really much time to cool
down
oh now I'm playing Jasper okay
okay
uh well here we go I assume yeah
Jocelyn's also in a tie for first
so I played Jasmine last week had a good
game against him like he narrowly won
so important to manage my time
aha
let's play this move
I actually prepared this in
Abu Dhabi for my final round of opponent
I think e4za move here the E4 or no it's
H5 first
Bishop B4 H6 now I think it's E4
I don't remember my analysis though
there's some crazy lines here
I like sakshi 2 as well
I really should know what I'm doing
and I'm still offering G2
idea Rook G3
I play D5
and just Knight F3
foreign
[Music]
in playing a very
suspect opening
each war on move three
around before
the queen D2
it was Queen E3 as well
Bishop defense C2
I want to play 95. also threatening A3 I
think
just trap the knights
I don't think Bishop B6 was a great move
foreign
96
some G4 ideas now
also Queen G3
losing D4 maybe but
it's messy G7 is hanging
I defend D4
thank you
another seven Queen G6
King probably wants to run to F1 or G1
Central is a queen
hmm
foreign
still some fight
foreign
defended that
oh no my queen
this is not gonna end well
okay resign
good game what a game
things felt good at some point there
like in the
in the early middle game
oops let's switch the scene
I'm not sure how much time I'll have
till the next game but uh yeah this H4
move
I prepare I mean the last time I looked
at this was in August
during the final round or before the
final round of Abu Dhabi
and each word is one of the top engine
moves I think
H4 is up there
and the idea is just to play H5
okay you played H6
okay I I clearly got confused I'm so
supposed to play Queen D3 here
what's the line at some point white can
play E4 maybe after C5
c5h6
there's a B4
ah still H6
and just castling
okay let's look at a little bit later in
this game
yeah it felt Pleasant for me around here
I don't think I'm like ever winning
though
yeah it might be it was very strong
oh okay new game starting
not much time for analysis
here we go playing
Leon osbell
good luck to my opponents
you switch the scene
yeah for everyone watching I'm not
really looking at chat during these
games
trying to say extra focused but we do
have the Armageddon command or more
information
so this is round six
I'm four out of five
okay no stop for gambits I'm playing
Sicilian I'll play taimanov
yeah this is a line
hey the main line is Queen G8 Bishop 494
and 94 is like the final move I know I
think A6 probably
I could also take and then
play A6
it feels like nice structure for black
Bishop D7
some greenless metal game
maybe Knight D5 soon
maybe not
E5
nah
a little bit stuck here maybe Knight D5
wanna play A5
foreign
a little bit
foreign
[Music]
so I think ticks I take
King E3 Knight F3 yeah I just Rook B6
I miss Rook B1 though
I can take on G2
there's also 98.
wow C5
and the sun move
I have this move though
and just losing material
Bishop a and I take
I always playing well
wait watch oh wow
um is there any way to explain this
so let's move
on a move
and go for this
in Rook B5 I have um
man
really getting no chances
a lot of nice ca2
I mean
opponents finally taking time but
what to do
like and I see it's a pretty easy tactic
to spot
it was strange though
and those still Matrix
ah I got all played there
yeah I think I just like
I just underestimated the playing the
queen side
so 94 there's probably a few hundred
games
so this is the main line
and Bishop E3
yeah but actually already be slightly
better
D1
I mean we left Theory pretty quickly
I lost control
probably when I tried to be too clever
Queen side
yeah around here like I played Rook d8
which is still playable
thinking yeah King E3
I'd miss Rook B1
and then C5 is just crushing
yeah it's not for Rook B1 it's uh like
it's fine for black
so I had to take but then it's already
like a little bit unpleasant
might be three
it should be close to equality
okay I'm four of the six
final games of this round are wrapping
up
um top ten
yeah duck chess will happen in the
future
but we have um
we have another game playing William
[Music]
Let's uh see my opponent from Brazil
Arena Grandmaster
okay
you have a dutch
wait did I play this opponent last week
or um the first Arena
we may have gone into some similar
opening
King h8
let's play this
I did encounter a Dutch last week
all right let's focus here
E5
Bishop H2
sometimes this just calls for positional
chess
I'll trade a little bit
Knights Knight Knight B5
it looks scary it's about my queen of
line with the bishop
I guess I'm allowing 95.
um night uh Knight G4
really trade
I mean there's Queen E5 now and then we
can go into some end game
okay
oh
I forgot that came with check
yeah this could be very very Josh
well I don't think black's gonna take
and so I mean black has a bishop here
if black takes it's then it's clear box
going for a draw
okay
Bishop B3
it's also Bishop E2
or Bishop D5
encountering Rook c792
and I'm probably a little bit worse here
in Bishop B5 we trade
you're a B3
basically offering the trade of Rooks
so take and Rook
I might just be losing a pawn
yeah I'm losing a pawn
one
that's not good
foreign
keep the Rooks on the board
at this point I'm just trying to survive
ip6
play A4
I'm actually happy to see that
then there's chances to simplify
we gotta play A4 here
for rookie two Rook B4
this could come down to a Time scramble
which is
and probably what I want
okay now F2 is over defended so I can
mobilize uh F1 Rook
I'm his level
threading Rook D7
[Music]
um
oh that's annoying
I probably should have traded
some H4
H4 H5 could be interesting
yeah it's still far from over
ah going for the trade I mean I have to
trade
now we have one of these
this should probably be a draw but
who knows anything can happen
I think I should take
um
foreign
[Music]
and this is what I wanted some like
weird zuzuong type thing
wasn't quite zugs long though
[Music]
oh no
ah I should have taken the draw
oh to do
what to do
opponent played was it
Rook B1 at the right moment I miss my
chance to take the pawn
oh no time to waste
okay I'm playing the 1200
I think I was offered a draw I made a
sound at some points
but when you're like
when I'm Solo in time I have to focus on
making moves rather than
uh trying to figure out how to accept
the draw
okay
20 something seconds until the next game
oh I wonder if if it does automatically
clean threefold
not sure if we actually repeated three
times
in that game
anyway
um still at Four Points a ratings taking
a dip
do I play soccer Gambit no do I play
Budapest gambits no
okay we have a D4 opening
I'll play against the London
okay this is what I like to play as
white
okay at least we have some like
compositional line
and Bishop B2 is actually my move of
choice
it's a slower variation
it was very solid
B6 first
foreign
yeah these readings don't actually
reflect ability I don't think
point from the US
like my phone's definitely not 1200.
uh let's take
I'm going for Queen G5
yeah I probably don't mind the queen
trade
and then
I mean overall the structure is a little
bit preferable for black
there's potential to to make progress on
the queen side
yeah Knight D2
I'm inclined to play Rook F4 here looks
like a crazy move
but it prevents Pawn F4
Knight G6 is coming soon
your Rook C8 B5 E4
H4 is a good move
I'm missing a lot of things today
which was a really good move
I take okay I could take with Chuck and
then save The Rook
oh we're gonna have another Rook ending
objectively I it's probably close to
equal
and White's gonna have some pressure on
the king side I'll have some play on The
Queen side
I'm up a lot of time
maybe it's worth taking verse
before next
trying to figure out what's playing here
like Rook F3 to F6 but then I have Rook
h8
uh F4 F5
okay
so I can take take
also just ignore it
I just want to win upon on the queen
side
so Rook C3 I take on B2
and pawn take C3 I play Rook C8
winning upon
an offline
[Music]
maybe they just lost connection
yeah I think connection has been lost
maybe it's our rage quits but it's not a
position where you Rage Quit though
uh what to do
the Zen button will hide oh I forgot to
change the thing
oops
this is the scene I have been using
okay
I won by forfeit
that's a walkover
I'm top 10.
five five out of the eight
okay
yeah Jose Martinez is in first
strong Grand Master
Blitz specialist bullet specialist
okay let me switch the scene here we go
okay
hopefully this is good
and I'm playing
another player from Brazil
Edgar
I think I'll just stick with my main
repertoire go for London
try and just play solidly
foreign
again I had this line earlier
so C5 is the main move
using Knight C6 Bishop D3
I've seen been seeing a mix of Knight C6
and Knight t7
and black can still choose
yeah so there's a few options there
and queen F3 first
preventing Knight E4
uh
uh did I go wrong
I guess I have to take
he tried to steal the idea
I want to play H6
and The Blacklist H6 something can take
never mind
three there's also G4
and G4 looks fun
it might not be right but the prospect
of G5 looks fine
okay so I can take
I've taken then G5
it is weird to like have traded off most
of the minor pieces
I've neglected castling
still attacking
Knight F3 the Bishops just kind of shut
out
it doesn't really influence the center
of black can't
put an island E4
the plan is probably to Castle and then
bring the a rook to G1 and just have all
the pieces attacking on the king side
up over a minute
if takes I take with Knight
I'm gonna have each six ideas
it's not clear like box plan
I mean G6 doesn't work let's take
I keep this structure intact because
I think it's very likely all Castle soon
six
so I don't want to play G6 I want to
take
this is a good move
and get all taken Castle
okay so now there's a few ideas like one
idea is to use the e-file
that might be threatening Queen R5
a trade into a better end game
another idea is night
Knight H4 to G6
or Knight of five
and there's Queen D6
oh there's a funny line
there's a line where I play Rook takes
E6 Rook E6 Queen E6 Queen E6 Mana f8
like it wins the pawn
okay I also have F4 here
and go for F4
like Rook G1 may be coming
foreign
looks pretty good I didn't want any
material but it looks like full
domination
what to do next a five
hmm
go after E6 somehow
not actually seeing the Breakthrough
but I guess I can kind of just wait and
see if black gives me an opportunity
like Queen G7 I have no fades
so Black's waiting to
I really want to play a five
the A4 first
always play King B1
always play King D2
gaming space
wow
I do have to be careful
tick tick
foreign
[Music]
I didn't want to take too many risks
there
I'll build the King on E3
Roblox fighting well
Queen H5 Queen C7 ends the game
oh no my queen
okay
GG
I took work opponent's offended well
also there's probably not much time
until the next game
okay
sixth place with six points
I might play elshon next
here we go
playing Jesus
you switch the scene
here we go
I think if my opponent doesn't move
in the first 30 seconds okay never mind
they moved
Knight H6
uh I feel slightly disrespected
this is an opening though ideas to play
F5 at some point
I wonder if I can play this move
threading Queen D2 to trap the knights
it starts King each a knight G8
the Box gonna have to do that
probably Knight C3
it's Pleasant development E5 probably
coming
should Castle
and queen side makes some sense
let's start with this
Bishop G4 Knight H2
oh
D5 looks interesting
and D5 is probably called for
g595 takes ticks
oh wow
that's so tempting to stack on G5
I think I'll hold off though
and there's really no need
about five coming
defend the knights
there's still some sock ideas
is this Pond just hanging
yeah that was a free Pawn
I mean Knight B7
there's no f72
and F7 should seal the deal
take on d8
I wrote G7 the king's gonna be uh
smushed in the corner
foreign
so the bishop has no moves
there is B6 but Bishop f8
and it's too much fun
[Music]
um
I'm threading Bishop H6
okay let's
I mean this
oh there's so many ways to win
let's play this first
look at this
controlling most of the seventh ring for
the Bishops
okay traveling The Rook
okay
that's a nice game
oh that was around 10. so there's one
more game
oh I'm probably gonna play elishon has
elshon played the top
I assume Alshon has played everyone
above
wow
we both have seven points too
I guess there's some small chance I
could play like below
we'll see what happens
I'm probably gonna be Vlog next game
so I think I was white the last two
games
okay here we go
oh not playing Alshon
playing this person also with seven
points
okay let me switch the scene
and good luck
okay this is the money game
if I win this game I might win more than
25 Euros
if I lose I might win nothing oh this is
oh did I play this person last week I
think I played this person last week
we had some I played some Cambridge
Springs I remember that game
it's actually a cool game
I might mix up the opening this time I
might play some um like A6 qgd
let's get something fresh
foreign
of mine
I was losing to this person last time we
played
okay
interesting
H6 or G6
I like H6
I wonder if I had Knight C6 there
hmm
I want to go for C5
a knight G7 C5
play C5 right away
takes 97
try it
so I have a C4
like keep the tension I'm not sure if I
want to push or take
now I could take on each floor
it's committal
it's actually really risky
start by taking
foreign
[Music]
everything to try and open the king side
so one plan is Queen R6 King f8 King E7
I mean I am up what two Pawns
of two pawns here
it's not clear what White's follow-up is
and G6 is some idea
really
no G6 looks good
idea of King G7
if Knight D5 I play Queen F5 and win
material
and that's a desperation move
I think it's okay to
let me just take it
last time I played this opponent he
resigned like once he lost material
I think he's probably in the fight here
keep attacking the queen
keep attacking
three
I mean everything's under control
take on D4
oh no
and completely blunder that
I think it's still okay like even though
I'm losing the knights there's uh Queen
D7 Rook C3
man
my Rook guards uh G6 from a distance too
it's all okay
if Rook out three Queen G1
wow
completely miss queen E7
so Rook H7 is idea
it's clever
I think just Knight F6
maybe Queen F6
wait a minute
I take
Queen F6 makes sense
so if Queen D7 again Rook C3
now I'm turning Rook C1 Queen B2 mate
oh no my Rook
okay
that's a tricky game
good game
attack worked out
so now I guess I just wait
I'm in second I'm in second place
let's see my tie breaks
yeah games are still going hey I'm in
second
despite losing three in a row earlier
uh elshon is probably gonna pass me if
he wins
so I guess I'm rooting for a draw
between Alshon
oh against opponent who beat me earlier
oh elshon's losing wow
is elshon losing
I wish I'm lost
wow this guy who beat me earlier and
like overtakes second place
so maybe I'm in third
Place wins 75 euros
uh although Kevin Corey
is still playing
if Kevin Corey wins
I get 25 Euros
I think
playing this person
yeah White's winning too
okay still finished in the money
that was fun
I'm kind of Topsy Turvy
result
you can watch the final games wrap up
Black's still fighting here
the lights lights in full control
go oh
oh no your Rook
oh
I see what happened
okay I didn't want to say anything but
maybe other people see what happened to
oh and I got my point back so I uh
okay
yeah it was like it wasn't a hundred
percent at least based on my game but
yeah I guess that's what happens so that
I actually take 30 seconds
because I got the point back
and
even though Kevin Corey won I I edged
out
Kevin on tie breaks
wow
what's second place
250 euros
okay that's uh
that's a nice day of work
yeah I think that's that's probably a
good practice like if someone is caught
during a tournament then the
but players that they beat should be
refunded their their rating and their
point
well good job to the top ten I think all
the games are done now
ah so that means elshon okay also elshon
finishes with the one point
so I managed to avoid playing Alshon
I really thought I was gonna play him
last round
yeah generally it's um
everyone has their own approaches to
handling these situations but the
approach that I take is even if I'm
suspicious or even if I'm like 99 sure I
don't call people out until it's checked
with the platform
so I mean because there's times where
people can just play your games but then
there's other times where
yeah there should be
there should be some investigation